well I think you see in the end this is
a question that you know I used to have
to answer this question a lot and it's
it's in the end of sort of curious thing
because I used to say to people well
first of all if I am of religious faith
and I happen to be the Prime Minister
it's a bit weird if I have to kind of
deny it or conceal it right and actually
it's not very you can't really do that
because someone's bound to catch you
going to church one day and so you'll be
out of so and when people talk about
decisions being I think the more
important thing is when they're all
about decisions being made on faith
grounds I mean I always used to say
there's a very clear distinction to me
between religious faith playing its part
in shaping my political character and in
given me a sense of values that of
course I bring to my political
decision-making because that's what
political decisions are about but I
always used to distinguish between that
because if you you're not careful that
slips into certainly in the media world
we live in you know people used to say
this by myself and George Bush over Iraq
it's not a religious decision now the
fact that you are somewhat of religious
faith you may bring certain values to
your decision making but unfortunately
and this is the problem I think I've
said to you before about religious faith
is it doesn't tell you the right answer
in policy terms you can give you your
values but it doesn't tell you whether
it's a good idea or a bad idea you know
I used to say to people if you go into a
corner and pray to God he won't tell you
the what the minimum wage should be next
year it just doesn't it's not like that
if it was governing would be a lot
simpler can assure you you just say I've
have asked and there it is so there's no
point having innovate about it we've
settled that so I I think that what I do
think is though that political leaders
and people used to even I used to say
the reason I don't talk about my faith a
lot in politics the UK's that's not our
tradition let me say gee that was one
reason why
right the other reason I didn't is
because I do think that political
leaders have got to be obedient to the
essential principles of the democracy we
were setting out and I personally would
feel uncomfortable if my leader of my
country was taking decisions I don't be
motivated in the general sense by their
faith because that's what they are as a
person but we're saying you know this is
this is instructions from God that's why
I'm doing it I mean that that would make
me you know I'd sort of them start
building the bunker roundabout then I
think so so I think you you know you
what I would say is you can't ignore the
fact of faith in someone's lives are how
they developed their character but I
think it is incumbent upon political
leaders and positions of authority to be
careful with how they use that and
careful as to how they articulate or
explain it because you can if you're not
careful and collide with what I think
are pretty essential principles of
liberal democracy